κινακάπως αμου επιτρέπε την έκραση τα ανήματα για τις θέσις των παιδιό τούτο νομίζω δε
δεν υπά δεν είναιαλήθεια διότι δε τα παιδιά μου έκαμα ότι εκάμα θέλοντας να το
κάμον οι ίδη και παίρνοντας στις δικές τους αποφάσεις θας είπαο να πό τη γνόμημου
αλλά ως εκεί εγώ δεν είμαιδεν ασχολούμε μεμε αυτά τα με αυτά τα πράματα τούτο
δεν είνα αλήθεια πάντος υπήρξαν πράγματα σαν αυτό που υπόθηκαν που σας ενόχλησαν και μπορας
ικόσανε το τηλέφωνο να πείτε φτάνει πλέο άγματα πουμε ενόχλησαν νάξει πράχαν καμιά φογά στες
εφημεριίδεσις ας πούμε τότε που εξεκινήσαν και συζητούσαν όταν έφυγεο τάσως απόυ την προεδρία τότε
είχαν αφήσει στο σπίτι δύο ασυνονικους να όταν εξεκινήσανται συζητήσειστες βουλστη βουλή και πι έχουν
αστυνομικού σκεποιοι δεν έχουν και ξέογω τότε έγραψα και εγώ ένα γγράμμα στον αχίου αστυνομίας
τους είπασας ευχαριστώ πάρα πολύ που που είχα τεδώσειροστασία ηδιομήνες τοισμία πόσε ήταν αλλά δεν
χρειαζούμε προστασία και τς πτούς ι διότι ήταν κάτι εποούσαν καθελείου συζητούν αγιιπου πάει και
σαν κουτσον πολύτηλέων ι χουν π δεν έχουν ντάξει αμε ενόχλησε τότε που εγάψαν ότι
καα έρευνας που είχαν πάρει τις ογώ ς πούμε στην περιοχη της τράκα αν και
ας πούμε θαθα τον πέίρναμε και ναεσιωρεσμένα πράματα ναι που πορείνα να είναινα μην είναι
ευχάριστα